moi j'ai j'ai des bus tec chabrol dans
un double tour et j'ai pris le plus
volée de bois vert dans le rôle que je
jouais de lazlo kovacs je me suis fait
traiter de deux chargeurs d'acteurs qui
ne fera jamais rien qui n'arrivera
jamais à rien nucléaire mais jamais rien
dit ou finalement ce rôle m'a bien aidé
peut être que maintenant dans les
critiques on va dire que c'est la fin de
ma carrière ex rouges fait que le puma
sera très bien ce que je pense
moi je suis pour la beauté morale et la
beauté morale ne l'ait trouvé écho chez
les mouche tout le monde me raconter
belmont bon c'est insensé avant de faire
une grande des scènes d'émotion à
continuer là dans dix ans tourne ekra
qui se met à pleurer
et oui mais ça veut dire j'ai toujours
fait ça et quand j'étais au
conservatoire me prenez pas au sérieux
parce que j'étais décontracté on a
toujours reproché à l'art mais aussi à
l'armée je m'en faisais préfère de
carrière dans l'armée mais au théâtre et
au cinéma même maintenant je veux je
débute un film je vois les gens très
inquiet parce que je tire pas des grands
propos sur mon rôle je n'explique pas
les profondeurs et comment je vois que
ce personnage marche
j'explique pas comment va être sa
coiffure ou sa salle et ça choque
toujours beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
il suffit pas dans votre ferme avec sa
taille
voilà j'aime mieux qu'on me reproche de
faire des films tropez
parce que c'est je suis qu'un moment
quand j'ai fait ce métier c'est pour que
beaucoup de gens me regardent jouer
sinon je me mets devant ma glace et puis
je joue puis je me trouve très bien
bon je crois qu'il faut pas avoir honte
d'être acteur est ce que je crois c'est
un peu la mode en ce moment beaucoup
d'acteurs du jeu d'acteur c'est pas
suffisant je vais être autre chose je
vais tu metteur en scène où on se lance
dans la politique à tout va pour montrer
comme et qu'on est très profond et mais
je trouve que de faire du but c'est déjà
pas mal mais c'est une belle distinction
et moi j'aime beaucoup ce qui m'amuse
c'est de jouer pour tourner vers une
trop bonne santé et oui ça se perd dans
le cinéma
[Musique]